okay Sebastian are there
um places or situations or social
Gatherings where you wouldn't take Bobby
as your guest
but let's suppose a dinner with Scorsese
and the big guys
he's not coming not not because I got a
problem with Bobby because he's going to
leave in 20 minutes he's not going to
stay but you don't you don't do well in
that so let me touch that let me finish
that I just did a move a couple years
ago it's not out yet where it was Cate
Blanchette Jamie Lee Curtis all these
people are in it all right and we it was
during coven so we had to quarantine at
the Four Seasons in Budapest Hungary
right for two months right so every
night I have to eat all with all these
people okay yeah Kevin Hart everyone's
there you know I mean who else is in the
movie Jack Black Edward Ramirez all
these people and I learned how to do it
so you know I'm not listening to them
but I I but in my mind I'm like I think
that was a joke Kate just said
like I've learned how to do it he's
laughing
I don't do my jokes but my jokes are so
[__] weird so people think I'm just
kind of like this little nice kid wasn't
there a time when like there was an
Asian direct you kept standing up in the
middle of dinner and he like pushed you
back oh yeah that was yeah before
medication before medication because no
that's not what happened what I I did a
movie with Michelle Yao
you know what that is no yeah yo yo
she's in that new what's up everything
everywhere yeah and I was Crouching
Tiger Hidden Dragon I've never saw it
I don't watch movies okay so I it
doesn't I don't know what do you mean
okay she looks so much
yeah yeah that's not a good photo get a
better photo is that uh what's the rich
uh Rich uh yeah
so years ago I did a movie with um her
yeah that's her right and um we get
invited to um a dinner the Thai Royal
because it was in Thailand
tyrol family the president of Samsung
Michelle Yao and me and I had one cool
t-shirt that I got and half of it was
ripped so you can see my my left breast
yeah so they wouldn't even let me in the
restaurant right but then I go I'm in
the movie right and then they went to
got the producer producers like what do
you wearing you know I mean I go this is
[__] from some fancy designer or
whatever so I sit there with Michelle
Yao and um the president of in the Thai
royal family and I'm uncomfortable bro
right but the side tables were all the
assistants and younger people
so you know I I I told Michelle Yale a
joke I don't think she liked it it was a
joke tell us about the joke was
um so after dinner you should teach me
because he never saw the movie okay but
he did she did a movie called Crouching
Tiger Hidden Dragon yeah which there's a
lot of wires stunts a lot of big like
big stunts they're running on rooftops
and trees hopping on trees yeah yeah so
I go you know after dinner you should
teach me how to run on trees and stuff
and she goes it was wild walk
oh [__] that joke didn't work so I left
the table and I sat with the young
assistants and people and I had a great
time yeah laughing but meanwhile one of
The Producers is looking at me
and he's looking at me from the main
table he gets up he grabs my arm and
goes you're being rude and he dragged me
back to the beginning
so I had to sit back down you know what
I mean and yeah so so you don't know
what do you mean you don't know why
can't I get up why can't I get up I
don't know
[Laughter]
just like just general social graces of
kind of how things might operate yeah I
learned
I learned to do it so I took that
situation and then when I was in
Budapest with the other fancy people I
go you know what wear the nice shirt
shut your mouth and stay there and learn
how to do it I went to a synagogue with
these people on a Sunday I had to wake
up early and because Jamie Lee Curtis's
um
um Dad Tony Curtis had opened up a
synagogue in Buddha I don't even know
what a synagogue is but they put the
little hat on it and I woke up at seven
in the morning and I sat there with
everybody and I did all the Shalom
shaloms and then I did it all and I
stayed there for the whole time so I've
learned to do it because I want to work
in the business all right you know what
I mean I'm sexing the city I I you know
when when Sarah Jessica Parker's all my
scenes are with her so when she's
talking to me
I don't know what she's saying but I I
you know I'm there are you there are you
no I don't know what she's saying about
wine or whatever what Vineyard I go to
but I go I don't know I'm here
if she throws a question in in that
she's like well hey Bobby what kind of
wine do you like do you go
and then I go what was it well it's your
wine oh I mean
I'll say I'll be honest with her yeah
but mostly what I do now is when she
she's always like reading something and
it's always her and I in the cast shares
and I just kind of just go I play Candy
Crush you know because I don't want to
[__] it up you know man yeah I don't
want to [__] my life up so um number one
that was
an unbelievable podcast
oh it's over yeah
when he puts the ghost he had a little
ghost right there he put that up and
that means we've done it
oh that's that's how they do it yeah
well that's how we do it that's our
light that's our life that's your light
yeah it slowly puts